podcast game
bootleg cat podcast special guest is
here representing Jacksonville
Duvall for the dude our Breezy in this
[ __ ] Jada Breezy is in this
[ __ ] indeed for sure welcome man
appreciate it I see you came through uh
with drugs it was always good it's a
little bit of that good California
marijuana some of that good recreational
hit my hit my system right now not quite
recreational in Florida yet not quite me
to be medicinal though correct isn't it
medicinal
I know [ __ ] they're they're making
the cookies out there Rick Ross got a
dispensary he's about to open they got
to be something going on out there
uh I don't know I just know he um
he like to play with chicken and [ __ ] so
he likes to play with chicken yeah like
you know you open up Wingstops that's
all I really know
shout out to the lemon pepper yeah
purple steppers man you gotta get closer
to your mic you got to get closer to
your mic man
so uh what part of Jacksonville are you
from
so I like
I don't know how to really explain it's
just the north side [ __ ] but the north
side of Jacksonville biggest [ __ ] though
yeah like it's a lot of neighborhoods
just on the North side specifically
right that's a it's just that shit's
just big as [ __ ] Jacksonville some
people would say is uh
at the moment one of the more
violent places uh in terms of just like
if we're just talking about hip-hop at
all like I just feel like it's kind of
like a it's hot a lot of beef going on a
lot of back and forth a lot of people
wrapped up in [ __ ] why do you think the
temperature in Jacksonville is
is that
um
honestly
yeah oh this bro this [ __ ] that [ __ ]
been going on for Generations like this
ain't something that just started though
right like how everybody making it seem
only reason it's just starting because
they don't put because now the
spotlight's there yeah the music
Spotlight done right so not everybody
really starting to see it's nothing new
it's nothing new ain't nothing
yeah I think like obviously uh
some of the um
more prevalent artists from the city uh
shout out to well sure first of all
shout out to YK Osiris who's from yeah
he's from Jacksonville a lot of people
don't know that he was a lot of people
money but he's very talented young man
and he's from Duvall
little Duvall's from Jacksonville yeah
it's a lot of it's crazy though like
when you think about it Ace you know we
keep going you got Papa [ __ ] spinner
bins waffle with the chopper
spinner bins is like in court right now
right yeah right now
it's crazy yeah yeah
are you cool with those guys yeah
they're my brothers okay I just don't
know man because I don't ask you for the
wrong guy listen man I'm trying to stay
out of it man my name's Bennett and I'm
not in it you know what I'm saying
[ __ ] I just know that y'all y'all
Jacksonville [ __ ] dissed
differently yeah I don't I ain't gonna
lie to I don't really see the difference
between like I drill music and other
people it's a lot more disrespectful I
don't really see it though oh I see it
New York
I don't know man that New York name
dropped just like us though
I mean listen let's be fair
I haven't seen somebody in New York go
shoot a video at someone's gravestone or
do a video on a golf course
tell me who they smoked
it's very flagrant it's flagrant levels
of disrespect in Jacksonville where I'm
just like what the [ __ ] is going on over
there with these kids [ __ ] there's like
no there's like no law no code no like
boundaries that they won't pass like
this [ __ ] is by the way I've interviewed
both of them Ace fully off interview
both of them and I try to preach the
same thing to both of them like yo One
Day You're Gonna you're gonna grow up
and you're gonna regret this [ __ ] like
like [ __ ] you know what I'm saying like
and you're cool I know you're cool with
Ace and those guys and they're super
nice guys you know I've had Ace on my
show a few times he's a sweet dude
um for you like are you
like are you trying to disc like like do
you try to stay out of the mix when it
comes to worrying about local local
problems with people obviously your
career is on a high trajectory right now
um honestly like
I don't the type of person I am about I
don't say [ __ ] to people I ain't no [ __ ]
starter but once you started right
you're you're responding everything
ended
so not everything I'm gonna do
everything no you're not going to do
everything
but musically yes
well I ain't saying you know no I'm
saying I'm just saying like situations
period because like I don't go around
looking for trouble like that you see me
on the internet tweaking out I got a
reason like I had a valid reason
but people don't understand that though
do you feel like
you could ever get to a point
where you can be the bigger man and just
be like hey I'm doing better than this
person that's why they doing this I'ma
just leave it alone yeah for sure
for sure I um
really I did it
but I'm in my pride get in my I let them
pride get in the way Pride's gonna get
you [ __ ] up man yeah probably get you
[ __ ] up for sure for sure for sure
[ __ ]
but honestly
I feel like when when you become like an
adult officially it's not when you're 18
not when you're 20 it's when you put
your when you realize that pride is your
enemy bro that Pride [ __ ] will have you
doing a lot of [ __ ] that you should not
be doing all because you think
it makes you look weak or whatever the
[ __ ] it is you know what I'm saying like
the real gangster [ __ ] is to be like
I'm not even gonna get my energy into
that [ __ ] keep it moving
yeah
but you know what I gotta feed you I
gotta give you some my my mushroom
gummies you're gonna eat a whole bag of
those and you come on the other side
you'll be like man up [ __ ] [ __ ] it bro
no more none of this [ __ ]
nah like I ain't gonna lie to like I
really don't care about the like the
[ __ ] that's going on in Jacksonville
yeah because like I don't stay there
anymore you you removed yourself from
the situation yeah I don't understand
Florida at all just all where are you at
um
um I ain't in Florida it's a different
state way different state yeah yeah
that's fair yeah I don't really
I don't really be in tune and really be
caring about that [ __ ] no more like
people can't even piss me off like that
no more like I get pissed off by some
whole other [ __ ] that's not related to
the to some Street [ __ ] going on smart
man yeah so like and then that's what
I've been like that's another thing like
I don't prove that I can bubble in music
without without the op killing music
yeah like I got a whole album called who
am I yeah you did good you feel me so
like I don't really too much care for
that [ __ ] no more I feel like too A lot
of these labels and
people are like they really take
advantage of
I I just man to me the Jacksonville [ __ ]
is so crazy like if I was a label
I'd be like we can't put this out man
like we can't put this up yeah I mean
numbers don't Lotto yeah but like at
what cost yeah you know what I'm saying
hey let me tell you something you know a
million streams on Spotify pays you
thirty eight hundred dollars so what are
we talking about here yeah I mean
um who did you grow up listening to who
would you consider to be like your main
influences when it comes to just rapping
and being an artist
oh [ __ ] oh I came up on Chief Keef yeah
when Chief Keef came out 2012 my whole
life changed for the better like I just
was a different person like he hit the
city hit the city of Jacksonville hard
like real hard right and I ain't saying
like because you know you got older
people in Jacksonville that was like
grown when he came out right but I'm
saying like for my age range or people
that's like in a 23 24 yeah and she keep
it hard everybody became a Sosa in the
city like everybody was putting Sosa
behind their name everybody wanted to
lock they have like everybody when you
see a [ __ ] with trash
this dress in his face you can't see his
face you hear me everybody wanted to
start drinking lean everybody wanted to
start wearing True Religion like that
[ __ ] just changed the city Jesus I mean
yeah I mean I think you know Chief Keef
is one of the most influential rappers
ever
I think when it comes to the last
probably 15 years
he's probably at least the last decade
no the last decade he's number one for
sure it's like him or future
for sure but I think anytime I talk to
an artist like they always say Chief
Keef oh no though because like
me when I was growing up I had like I
was around my big brothers and y'all
like you might be right my family member
right Brothers but literal Brothers yeah
like they was on future hard like they
what got me on to Future yeah so around
that time like
sonically you hear future in everybody
now
like sonically sort of a sense you kind
of hear hints of future or Thug in
everybody now sort of a sense in terms
of not everybody but when you hear the
artists who do like heavily do melodic
[ __ ] you hear future and post Malone you
hear future and I might go on and on and
on like his influence is vast in terms
of just like the style of music whereas
I Feel Like Chief kee's influence on
just the internet the way people were
dressing obviously the drill [ __ ] which
went over to the UK came back went to
New York went to Jacksonville it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah
I ain't gonna Honestly though
I would say
as of now as in like
this year of rappers yeah
you want to be real no baby
nah who look like little baby he's just
like baby that's another topic who do
you think is most influential right now
in his own world like when you hit when
you hear rappers who do you kind of feel
like they're most influenced by
today
coming from a Florida person I say call
that a hundred percent
so that for sure there's so many baby
Kodak blacks yeah you're right
he started away for sure
Kodak started a whole even most
influenced Robert right now I was living
in Tampa
um when Kodak was uh I DJ for Kodak when
he was like
he was a kid so it was very it was like
2014 2015 but it was crazy to see like
what my own eyes his Florida glow up
explored as his own country that's his
own world like coming up in Florida and
then like going to other states it's so
different and even like Florida you
could drive an hour in any any direction
in Florida and the whole culture is
different yeah yeah like if you go to
Jacksonville it's different than if it's
in Tallahassee or if it's in Orlando and
Orlando's different than Tampa and
nothing's like Miami everybody thinks
Florida and they think of Miami it's
like bro that's the only place Miami is
the only
well Miami's the only place that's like
Miami and Florida everything else is
very much like
cut like like not country but you know
Florida country like you know like you
might be I mean you you know man
Florida's its own [ __ ] place and not
none of it is like Miami yeah everything
is different down there yeah that's what
I hate about that [ __ ] like people
that's not from Florida the first thing
they say is like Miami like they think
in Miami where they think of Disney
World yeah like they think like the
whole Florida is based off that one is
not of course you go to Orlando bro like
that [ __ ] is way different like my first
time ever going to Orlando and seeing
like Orlando [ __ ] bro like that [ __ ]
is way different bro you go to Tampa
Tampa [ __ ] is way different St Pete
[ __ ] is Wade yeah I lived in the same
people that's where I lived yeah St
Pete's wild they different bro just
everything's just different you'll never
go to a city in Florida and get the same
and all the music uh that works there so
like I lived in Tampa and we in Tampa we
have music Juke music so it's like [ __ ]
with cowbells like 100 bpms like party
club [ __ ] but you drive an hour
uh to Orlando they are not playing none
of that [ __ ] I don't know what Orlando
be doing well Orlando's like baby New
York
everybody from New York goes there's a
lot of Puerto Ricans Orlando like if
it's popping in the club in New York is
popping in Orlando Tampa's like Florida
you'd be like Oh I'm just some floored
bro I remember
hearing Plies album cuts when I was in
the club in Tampa when I first moved
there the whole crowd said my yo wait a
minute that [ __ ] I've been all over the
country this [ __ ] Plies is
really the God they're playing track
seven from his 10 year old album and all
crowd singing it oh God flies you
applies huge yeah we uh before
um
chief
Plies in Florida yeah flies was that man
that [ __ ] oh my god well he uh and
boozy Boosie y'all damn
it's a I ain't that's a lot of
[ __ ] that hit see because I
think now like I think boozy obviously
puts out a lot of music but I think
people look at him now as more of a
personality where it's like yo unless
you've lived in the South you don't
understand that [ __ ] is like the
South's Tupac yeah when he got out of
prison that [ __ ] was different he hit
hard that um show the world but when he
got out of prison it was like it was
like uh
I never seen no [ __ ] like that like that
he was getting stupid bags
and just people were like yo they really
like boozy's like he's uncancelable
because the people who rock with him
rock with him in such a deep way that
it's like it doesn't matter what he says
or what he does it's like it's boozy
like who's he got boozy got my dad a
generation like yeah like when I was
little when I was growing up watching my
daddy bro all he do [ __ ] yeah he'll
have him a Buick a song that better be
painted up bedrooms got the base in that
[ __ ] and all his [ __ ] that's
all that's playing through the car oh
that's all I used to hear when I was
little hey we got to stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our newest
partner to the podcast shout out to our
family at hardean Las Vegas man listen
uh the number one dispensary in the
world I don't give a [ __ ] man craziest
dispensary with the most selection they
got so much weed in this [ __ ] place
you go to Las Vegas you're [ __ ]
feeling good with your homies it's
recreational you're like damn I could
just go into a store and buy weed yeah
but you just can't go into any store in
Las Vegas to buy weed gonna walk out
with some [ __ ] [ __ ] no you go to
hard Dean tell them I sent you all right
make sure you follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see it down
there you see the [ __ ] sweater
we represent and by the way can we shout
out
to them for sending me this this bootleg
head podcast
thingy
what is this called
no no it's uh for cigars
humidor yeah the humidor now this is
what's great about it we might start
doing this for our smoking guests
you know we might have to bust open the
Hardy and humidor
and just get into some of these treats
you know what I'm saying a little bit of
the treaties you know straight from
Hardy in Las Vegas even I mean
these are totally props because you know
they're props but with that being said
when you go to Vegas telling bootleg Kev
sent you Harding Las Vegas I'm telling
you it is like going to it's like the
Bentley of dispensaries it's so nice the
weed is the best the selection is the
best the bud tenders are the best and yo
make sure you shoot them a follow
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas
go to hardine baby all right you already
know let's get back to the interview
um
Jacksonville obviously the people who
aren't from Jacksonville and live in
Florida they call that [ __ ] South
Georgia because it's like right there at
the border like when we're in Tampa they
would refer to Jacksonville it's like
South Georgia oh no I'm just letting you
know I'm letting you know what your
Tampa people are saying about you
because it's so close to the [ __ ]
border it's right there it's like at
that top of the corner of the state
like
no but I'm just curious like um like
when you were growing up were you
getting to Atlanta a lot were you would
you like because it's not that far of a
drive from Jacksonville no I ain't never
seen Atlanta until I was
I want to see
18 or 19. oh yeah we were a grown-up
yeah yeah I ain't never left my city
before
damn who are some of your favorite
artists in your city
um not your friends
I'm not saying the Ops either but just
in general you know there's some great
guys out all right almost his name
people yeah people I listen to uh
like even if they are friends like still
name them all right go ahead man you
don't have to name just name who you
like all right um
papa for sure listen a little papa for
sure he just signed with see who's did
he just sign uh yeah yeah well CMG right
yeah yeah
Oh Yo Gotti signing everybody it's a
[ __ ] pick a city he's got an artist
I fought with uh I fought with mm bar
uh
you got green light you got spin events
I wobble with the chopper that's a crazy
rap name
Whopper with a chopper hey can you
connect me with him I want to just hang
out with that guy oh yeah he got a
personality out of this world with the
name like wobble with the chopper I
would hope so yeah I ain't gonna lie
what was here right now we'll all be in
this [ __ ] laughing I love it
that's just him okay that boy got a
personality out of this world but
um
it'd be so crazy if that was his name
but he was like he got that name from
being a chef
I'm dropping veggies like really good
you know
I don't get it I know never mind I was
just saying like imagine like
everybody's like oh wobble with The
Choppa we know what that's about because
he's a rapper but then you met him and
he was like a five-star coach Chef yeah
and he really got that name because he
was at a five-star restaurant he could
chop them veggies faster than everybody
yeah yeah that would be crazy
as you could tell I'm high and and I was
drinking earlier with G herbo so you
know
so wobble with the chopper yeah you want
to name anybody else I'm trying to think
right now uh
[Music]
uh oh all right yeah um Backstreet TK
gmk
you know of course Ace them you know
basically that little group you know uh
that's about it though like I mean like
damn right or the other people I need
like I don't listen to nobody if they
from the city not white k o Cyrus oh
yeah all right yo yko sorry I ain't
thinking see like because right now all
I'm thinking is like what's going on
right now yeah so I mean so you're I
mean he's going on right now but in a
different way yeah like he's like he's
in another world I guess but yeah why
can't you uh very talented kid man yeah
he could sing his ass off that book is
saying like I didn't even know he was
from Jacksonville but I met his dad his
dad came to the radio station like three
or four years ago
and I didn't know where he was from but
I met his dad
and I was like yo you're from Florida
aren't you and he was like how'd you
know I'm like bro you're your dad looks
like a floor I've lived there I know
like you're a Florida [ __ ] yeah
we just got our own look you could you
could spot a Florida person anyway
yeah I mean I I honestly you're right
I'll give you that for sure yes also the
craziest stories in the world when
you're on the news you're watching like
Instagram like if someone like crashes a
[ __ ] car into a Wendy's drive-through
because they're running from somebody
it's in Florida yeah
yeah
um like when I went in I had went to a
couple of clubs before in Atlanta and
like [ __ ] just pulling me off
the couch hey you from Florida you're
from Florida yeah yeah type [ __ ] yeah
Florida's a it's a it's an amazing place
I don't know what it is about Florida
that makes people do [ __ ] [ __ ]
though they call it Florida man have you
heard that when people say I by the way
didn't mean to just say [ __ ] with
all the respect but they call it the
Florida man strikes again so like have
you seen like during the um hurricane
Ian shout out to Fort Myers got hit
really bad there was like guys shooting
music videos in the middle of the
hurricane
somehow just now yeah
um
[Music]
I know you talking about because I
follow him on Instagram just hard uh
and then something you got dreads yeah
yeah he from I think he from Sarasota
sounds about right
I fought with him though I follow him
like he hard Sarasota is a great place
have you been to Sarasota you got to do
this club in Palmetto Florida Palmetto's
between Sarasota and Saint Paul metal as
in p-a-l-m yeah
all right yeah I don't see my listen
there is a club in Palmetto called the
hall
that is [ __ ] a good time
it's crazy though but it's like some
real Florida [ __ ] like Kodak used to do
that [ __ ] when he was coming up get
booked at the hall
hey I swear that's why that's why I
asked you how I was spelled because I
didn't check my DM Palmetto so
Palmetto's between Sarasota and Saint
Pete so it's like in the middle of the
state but it's a wild place man shout
out to Palmetto I'm surprised we haven't
had any rappers come out of Palmetto
[ __ ] hey what up y'all bootleg cab here
uh we gotta interrupt the interview and
tell you about our family at Blue Chew
look if you go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg to sign
up and you will get your first month of
blue chew for free that's right they're
gonna give you the first month of blue
chew for free all you got to do is pay
five dollars in shipping and you're
gonna get delivered right to your door
some great [ __ ] for your dick let me
tell you what it is all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction if
you're dealing with any sort of stress
and you just need an extra little uh you
know a little performance enhancer if
you will all right for you Johnson down
there all you got to do is go to
Bluetooth uh and use that promo code
bootleg and it's coming straight to your
door the same active ingredient as
Viagra as Cialis and then the new mint
chewable breaking news there is a new
mint chewable that blue shoe has just
introduced to the marketplace and it has
the same active ingredient it as Levitra
and stackson I'm going to try to tell
you about this active ingredient it's
VAR denafil
but
try it out supposed to be a little more
potent than the normal blue shoe
whatever you need regular blue chew the
new mint chewable whatever it is you're
gonna knock it out the [ __ ] Park all
right look Barry Bonds needed a little
performance enhancing when he uh hit 73
home runs back in the day he holds the
record still you might need a little
performance enhancement in the bedroom
your lady will thank you your wife will
thank you your boyfriend will thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you're into we're not
judging over here at the bootland cat
podcast but I am judging you if you
don't go to Bluetooth right now and sign
up with that promo code bootleg and get
a month for free try it out it's
literally free all right let's get back
to the interview Florida's so wild man
it's like okay it really is its own
country it's its own thing yeah no state
tax
I don't know too much about well you're
gonna have to figure out the taxes thing
yeah I know I know that I'm not I'm
saying like I don't really be getting
into topics like that well it's taxes
yeah that's fair
I mean look I I hear you're young
no it's not about me being young it's
just like you just hire an accountant
for that kind of [ __ ]
nah it's best to learn it on your own I
agree because the accountant can take
advantage of you yeah so like that's why
you know everything I do I'd rather do
it on my own and learn it Hands-On
because at what age did you get your
gold teeth uh uh I don't know I ain't a
lot to you over 18 under 18. under 18.
wow yeah that was a thing back then too
everybody was getting golds
I had a grill in Florida when I lived
there the driller hooked me up I had a
little bottom bottom side I ain't
[ __ ] with the diamond teeth
so
because yours are permanent right
they're not permanent she could pop them
in and out
I don't know I don't know what that
means my thing is you're not wearing a
grill those are your teeth
yeah yeah
have you regretted that decision as an
adult now now that you're older
no
Dental wise is there any different
things you need to do for dental care
because Norm you know obviously is there
like a special toothpaste is there
no
just use normal [ __ ] Aquafresh so it's
Florida [ __ ] right Colgate brush your
teeth [ __ ] I don't know if there's a
state there's not a spec there's not a
special toothpaste yeah if you have gold
teeth nah
it's a serious commitment though
it's a Florida thing though oh I know it
is it's just I don't know how to explain
it yeah how are the strip clubs in
Jacksonville
I could tell you all all like you don't
frequent the establishments
I'll do that type of [ __ ]
what's that type of [ __ ] like
like clubbing and [ __ ] like own club
like I don't go to parties you won't go
to the strip club to have some food
you'll be at the crib
that's fair
[ __ ] don't go down hey that's a safe
place to be you you stay out the way you
know [ __ ] is good yeah it's about being
smart not tough uh talk about the music
man what do you got out right now what
do you got coming uh uh I just dropped a
song called a single no Nick calling no
name dropping that'd be that like I
think it's like 800k in like two weeks
that's a lot of views yeah I just y'all
Gucci man too I saw that one shout out
to Gucci how the [ __ ] that happen I
don't need [ __ ] it though bro I saw the
guy you don't know how how it happened
Deadpool just send you a song and say
here this is yours what happened like my
manager hit me up
he was like he always had like he always
brought Gucci up type [ __ ] right you
feel me like he like hell man man Gucci
good friends type [ __ ] so I never really
like you know pay no attention because
I'm like [ __ ] you telling me like I'm
gonna get to work with this right right
so
one day I'm like I'm he texting we
talking and [ __ ] say like what you uh
doing today I'm gonna head to the studio
right now so it's like um I got
something for you he was like um
I'm gonna send you a beat and I want you
to uh here's like do something to it
type ships right all right you feel me
knowing but sometimes like when he send
me stuff like that
I try to stir away from the Shoot Em Up
bang bang [ __ ] because you never know
who yeah what he gonna do with it right
right that's fair I can't I gotta show
versatility of course so it's like
my all right so I did it and I sent it
so he was like man he was like this [ __ ]
fire so I'm like you dead ass like
because sometimes I ain't gonna lie be
said guessing he's like yeah this [ __ ]
fire watch this type [ __ ] he was totally
talking so
how about they send me the verse back
so I'm like I click that bit everybody
said Gucci
what the [ __ ] that's crazy so I remember
him like he kept bringing Gucci up right
remind you so I'm like damn so this way
he probably had to be sleep this whole
time so I hit a song like what the [ __ ]
it's all like I'll call my brother know
I'm like man what the [ __ ] out of song
Gucci man they like man stop lying so
I'm like man I swear to God I got a song
Gucci man so boom
I get around my brother though I play it
and like everybody just like sitting
there like
after the song end like everybody's just
not saying that I couldn't believe it
like yeah like and then my big brother
don't they grew up on Gucci like yeah so
it's like they sitting in that bed like
boy what the [ __ ]
that's so crazy like nobody just
couldn't believe this [ __ ] like we just
all sat there in silence like is this
[ __ ] real well I mean and you got the
video yeah that went through me too
that's that's like I'm sure a lot of
people I'm not a lot of people but I
mean look getting the versus one thing
we're getting the verse with the videos
crazy that threw me all the way out
because when I met him
like he's like he was like what's up Jay
that
I'm like [ __ ] like I can't I'm keep it
real like you feel because I grew up on
Gucci like of course my daddy doing all
that [ __ ] so it's like this [ __ ] a
legend basically like the [ __ ] basically
yeah for sure yeah like for sure that so
he like what's up Jade I just him saying
like what's up Jay like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I used to look at you on the TV
when I was like four five years old by
the way you're aging me so crazy right
now yeah
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick tell you about our partners at my
bookie that's right salute to the family
at mybookie all right it is so much
action to get in on right now in sports
we got the playoffs in baseball we got
NFL action every Sunday and NBA season
is upon us yes if you want to get in on
the action and make some of this money
with me I'll be gambling all damn day
I might have a problem with that being
said go to my bookie right now when you
sign up use the promo code bootleg and
they will match your deposit all right
that's right your first deposit when you
sign up with a new account when you use
that promo code bootleg they're gonna
match it all right that means if you put
in 500 bucks you get another 500 for
free to gamble with yeah all right I'm
loving uh some of the Futures too uh I
love the over on wins for the Sacramento
Kings and the NBA season coming up I
think they're going to have a good year
I'll also beta over on the Phoenix Suns
they're gonna have more than 52 and a
half wins what are we talking about plus
NFL action every Sunday let's get this
money go to mybookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg all right
when you do that they're matching your
first deposit off the rip no matter how
big or small let's run that [ __ ] up go
to my bookie right now use that promo
code bootleg and get your first deposit
matched free money to gamble with with
my bookie let's get back to the
interview
that's what'd your dad say I don't even
talk to my dad oh well there's that yeah
just like you haven't talked to him for
a while
uh yeah that's fair we won't get into
your family problems don't worry cap
show is not for family oh no I don't
have family issues it is I don't this
[ __ ] yeah man my dad right now who else
is on your project
uh which one and what do you say you
just dropped oh no that was just two
singles I was just two singles okay so
when's the album coming out all right oh
soon because you're here for a reason
soon it's coming out soon but before the
end of the year
probably okay the beginning of the new
year all right all right
is that the name of the album knew me no
it's called don't [ __ ] with me later
Jesus but it's gonna be don't you know
what don't [ __ ] with me later I like
that I thought you were gonna just say
it's called don't [ __ ] with me that one
word changes the whole context of what
the [ __ ] title is imagine if you put
an Alabama card it's called don't [ __ ]
with me I'm like damn bro we know what
kind of time you're on
hey oh [ __ ] don't [ __ ] with me later
it's like oh I get it yeah [ __ ] with me
now cause you're gonna have to [ __ ] with
me later yeah yeah yeah I mean like
I'll go see have you tapped in with
Kodak at all uh uh nah he um he
commented on man uh walk song one time
well it was a whopping me song yeah
featuring me you so yeah he commented on
that bit one time it was like you feel
me he I feel like he'd be paying
attention man I mean yeah I feel like
every every bit artist in Florida see
what's going on in Florida because it's
like
it's Florida and then in Florida promo
Pages like everybody see that [ __ ] it'd
be people that's not even from Florida
following the Florida promo I follow all
the Florida promo Pages yes I I know
they see it yeah I know they see that
[ __ ] you like when you get on those
pages is that something that like you
initially had to pay to get on or did
they just post it because you're making
noise
because I think that sometimes artists
don't understand the benefit of maybe
investing in those kind of pages
[Music]
um
I don't want to be wrong but I think
majority of those not majority but some
of them Pages you used to have to pay to
get on that bit but like nah maybe
showing up people that's going growing
their own I could always tell the paid
the people that paid to
you know why because they always put
fire or dookie emojis are y'all feeling
this
post
are y'all feeling this fire dookie I'm
like oh this this that's that's
literally that's literally the paid post
am I lying that's it right
yeah but I think it's important for
artists to invest in those pages though
because like you could do if you're from
Florida you're from wherever and there's
like some popping blogs or whatever but
no honestly like
what people don't understand it'd be for
like all right people that's already in
into music understand that type of [ __ ]
right people that's on the outside
looking in they just know some [ __ ] like
oh [ __ ] you paid for that [ __ ] you you
cheating but it's like [ __ ] this is
music sell yourself you gotta invest in
yourself would you rather spend
money promoting yourself or money on
some [ __ ] it's like you're not
interested in the market like you got to
be able to but like that dude BFB the
Pac-Man he was invested he's fired yeah
great guy too great guy shout out to
Flint Michigan but he like kind of
started popping because he was getting
on say cheese right he was paying to
Beyonce cheese and that really like
changed his career because how many
hundreds of thousands of people millions
of people follow say cheese that see you
that they're gonna see it whether it's
good or bad
ain't nothing wrong with it's something
wrong with buying views but ain't
nothing wrong with paying for promo bro
100 there's nothing wrong with that I
agree fully it's smart man so top of the
year-ish
don't [ __ ] with me later yeah very
beginning of the years very big so it's
January probably yeah more singles
coming yeah a lot some raw [ __ ] a lot of
raw [ __ ] a lot of raw [ __ ] coming a lot
of raw [ __ ] yeah
yeah drilled that drill Jada that they
won't they can get that but when the
album will come
they gonna get a
all right
I don't know if you're my best one of my
best albums was the creation I haven't
heard it so yeah that's the album that
like changed your life yeah that did
numbers and [ __ ] right so this album
basically like a the creation too
but let me just call it don't [ __ ] with
me later what uh like for you
the Jacksonville drill things that's
very different than drill [ __ ]
everywhere else but obviously you know
drill music is drill music like what do
you think differentiates Jacksonville
and the hip-hop scene from the rest of
the countries
I don't understand all right I don't
know how else I'm gonna put this but I'm
Gonna Keep It Real
what makes you so basically you asked me
what made Jacksonville different from
everybody else yeah I mean of course
we're yeah all right so we'll make
Jacksonville different from everybody
else is me
okay me and my my homeboys basically all
right my my homeboys well this is what
makes us different because
those those beats you hear everybody rap
on right with those like it'll be like
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom those type of beats
what do you think Tweet [ __ ] came from
that [ __ ] started from me doing my Tweet
[ __ ] series you gonna hear the first
tweet [ __ ] ever it's called just Jada
Breezy Tweet [ __ ] and then you gotta
Tweet [ __ ] too they got Tweet [ __ ] three
ain't got Tweet [ __ ] four and all of
them was a success tweet isn't like
Twitter tweak I think you said hey
tweaking out what does tweak mean in
Florida
it can mean a lot of [ __ ] because I'm
from Phoenix well not really like
basically like you tripping okay because
I'm in there I'm from Arizona and in
Arizona tweak is meth what the [ __ ] yeah
be tweaking like yeah that's a tweaker
over there
so if like somebody if someone has
tweaked they got meth or if they're a
tweaker they're a [ __ ] they're a mess
they're a meth head back when I was
growing up my uncle was a tweaker he was
tweaking off that mess
but I know tweak don't mean the same
thing everywhere yeah that mean like you
tripping in in Florida like you're like
bro you tweaking like okay okay yeah
yeah
what do they call meth in in
Jacksonville just meth ice yeah yeah
probably I don't know yeah bad drug man
don't ever get that ah [ __ ] no hell no
just stick with the weed yeah and and
then add mushrooms to your repertoire I
ain't never did mushrooms
soon I'm gonna give you some gummies and
you're gonna take them You're Gonna
Change Your Life
hey what up y'all gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at Odd Socks that's right go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg that's right bootleg
you will save 20 off at checkout now
listen we know that they have amazing
socks these are sour patch kids socks
these are hot Cheeto socks
Half Baked you know what I'm saying and
uh you know for those that like Snapple
so much so that you would wear socks
with snapple's logo on them and all my
Naruto fans they have the Naruto but
let's bust these boys out you know they
they got the underwear and the underwear
are crazy love the draws what do we have
here
oh oh we have we have Hey Arnold
underwear
these are [ __ ] amazing Jesus I'm
gonna wear these you know why I'm gonna
wear those oh because I have
Hey Arnold socks on you see what I did
there yeah that's right we out here
represent Odd Socks the most comfortable
socks in the world I promise you if you
get your Odd Socks Basics like these
these are the basics right those are uh
I mean you're not going to get any
better than that you know what I mean
the odd Sox Basics are incredible all
right so uh that's my favorite I'm
always wearing a black or white pair of
Odd Socks Basics but uh don't like
listen to me try them out for yourself
go to oddsoxofficial.com use the promo
code bootleg save 20 off at checkout and
they got some new [ __ ] coming at the top
of the Year hmm I would say go to their
Instagram at oddsocks official
and just look at some of the shoes that
uh the owner's wearing in some of the
videos they may or may not be having
some slides coming out I don't know I
cannot confirm nor disconfirm but you
know they did put them on their
Instagram for a reason like a little
tidbit little little crumbs to what's
coming next year
plus they just dropped their monster
socks which I don't have any of those
here but it is Halloween season so go
[ __ ] with those you already know man odd
Sox official go [ __ ] with them on
Instagram go to oddsoxofficial.com and
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and when you do that you
support us you support the whole crew
over here at the bootleg head podcast so
let's get back to the interview
uh when did what age were you when you
first got to face tattoos
oh
don't I think I was
let's see 19.
it's a serious commitment to FaceTime
I'll be scared to do that [ __ ] man wait
it'll hurt it don't hurt no
I don't know if I believe you it just
felt like [ __ ] I bet you don't feel good
no it don't hurt like I ain't gonna lie
after like when it's finally done when
it's healing like not like when whenever
yeah two artists stop and like wipe it
and like it's that alcohol wipe you're
like oh that bit kind of burned yeah but
other than that no that's it don't hurt
it don't hurt at all well you just feel
like somebody popping bumps on your face
oh like a popping a zit yeah have you
ever been in a relationship where the
girl likes to pop zits
I don't know well then how would you
know what it feels like if someone's
popping bumps on your face okay I don't
Bro you've never been with a girl who's
like yo let me pop that and they want to
pop your [ __ ] zit for you
oh yeah yeah it was just like yeah but
there's something I don't know what it
is why do [ __ ] like popping zest bro
it's a weird thing to be a fan of
it's a thing though
yeah let me pop it yeah like yo what is
that's a strange thing I don't want to
pop yours go away
we're both high and I'm a little drunk
well listen uh don't [ __ ] with me later
yeah coming soon
some new records coming soon
a couple of new singles and videos are
out
Gucci Mane co-signing you
um
yeah shout out to Jacksonville just stay
safe man these this Jacksonville [ __ ]
has me nervous it's just like a fan of
hip-hop I just like I'll be interviewing
I'm like man this [ __ ] is it's different
over there man a lot of people be lying
I'm sure they do we're not even gonna
get into that was not the interview for
that you'll have that interview tomorrow
to get into I'm just saying like you
know I don't want to know who's lying
who's telling the truth all I'm saying
is [ __ ] stay safe bro life is
precious life is precious Jacksonville
life is precious
and
please
just lie on all your songs
I always lie all your songs are
fictional right I'm the best liar in the
world that's what I like to hear
songs are fictional it's art
keep that [ __ ] fictional I mean should I
be saying in my dreams I like that man I
appreciate you pulling up it was nice to
smoke some weed with you even though you
didn't pass it after we started the
interview I forgot this [ __ ]
took the whole [ __ ] down by himself he's
high as a giraffe [ __ ] right now
boom fire